[Musique]
aulas
durant 60 ans michel louvain séduit
accompagner son public
le québec pleure aujourd'hui la mort de
son plus célèbre chanteur de charme
pourquoi mon dieu quel point j'étais une
fan 6 me on allait le voir partir en
avion
il y avait une foule délirante à dorval
pour le voir partir
[Musique]
durant les années 60 le chanteur
déclenché une véritable louvain magna
sur son passage
l'udaf homme était au tout début du show
business lui a fallu les émeut nuit à
pogny les choses pour pas les plus
aujourd'hui une carrière exceptionnelle
durant laquelle il a enregistré plus de
36 fait des milliers de concerts aux
quatre coins du québec
en plus d'animer à la télévision mais en
contact avec les gens parce que il faut
que je sois avec les gens c'est ma
source de vie
[Musique]
hospitalisé depuis quelques jours pour
un cancer de l'oesophage la nouvelle de
son décès hier soir entraîné une
avalanche de réactions
c'est vraiment un deuil national
québec va me manquer écrit le mot
passion un pylône et mon produire michel
louvain sur scène ce gala était
tellement heureux
enfin un est fermée l'an à quelque part
il était émerveillé tout le temps on y
ait beaucoup quand on était enfant a dû
un monument c'est cesser un grain ça a
été l'idole d'un peuple et des milliers
de fans pleurent aujourd'hui la mort
d'une idole des femmes comme nicole
dupuis beaupré qui avait participé au
documentaire les dames en bleu qui nous
encouragent
c'est le bon moment qu'on a posé avec
les beaux moments puis s'était il
faisait partie de la famille
c'est qui le plus dur à accepter c'est
de le voir partir
travailleur infatigable michel louvain
espérer reprendre la route et retrouver
ce public qui l'aimé tant un public qui
lui est resté fidèle jusqu'au bout
ici nabi alexandre charti radio canada
montréal
[Musique]
toi qui m'as tout
vous donnez